bonsoir c'est sans doute un attentat
personnes ce soir ne peut se prononcer
avec certitude sur les causes de
l'explosion d'hier soir abords du
capitole le train paris toulouse mais
d'ores et déjà l'information judiciaire
ouverte par le parquet de limoges a
exclu en fin d'après-midi l'hypothèse
d'un accident
elle retient celle de la destruction
volontaire entre guillemets cet accident
représente donc l'attentât le plus grave
contre un train en france et il inquiète
le premier ministre a reçu d'ailleurs
cet après midi le ministre des
transports charles fiterman qui s'était
rendu sur place et celui l'intérieur
gaston defferre qui a décidé de prendre
un certain nombre de dispositions dans
les gares et dans les trains mais avant
toute chose les frais avec jérôme
kabylie hier soir vers 20h40 le capitole
lancé à 140 kilomètres à l'heure est
secoué par une énorme déflagration
il se trouve alors à vivy km2 l'image
des tôles broyées les pompiers les
services de gendarmerie les sauveteurs
bénévoles vont retirer cinq corps pour
la plupart mutilés et 29 blessés plus ou
moins gravement atteints des sièges
arrachés des tôles broyées sont
éparpillés sur le ballast jusqu'à 200
mètres à la ronde
le wagon l'ironie state s'est ouvert
comme une boîte éclaté et une vaste
déchirure s'ouvre sur le côté droit
j'ai entendu l'explosion elle est là la
fenêtre à côté à ma droite quoi est ce
qui est curieux c'est que j'ai été
baissés de ce côté là
alors je perdais moment ça un abattage
et j'avais bien peur que ce soit
l'artère qui soit on a vu sa gloire les
deux ici et trois dans un wagon là-haut
et les blessés on une douzaine je me
suis couché
parce que j'attendais que le rail que le
train a déraillé
quand ce n'est pas arrivé je me suis
levé aussitôt je suis précipitée dehors
et quand la juguler
je suis arrivé dans le wagon celui là
vous avez entendu des gens qui se
plaignaient de police secours on a fait
ce qu'on pouvait gérer les gens qui
saignait on a dégagé une dame qui était
sur une banquette
la réponse et en a sorti en appel tandis
que le wagon déchiqueté été remorqué sur
une voie de garage les lieux de
l'accident était très vite déblayé pour
ne pas gêner le trafic ferroviaire très
dense sur cette ligne accident à deux
politiques geste criminel
tout est envisagée par les enquêteurs on
parle beaucoup ici d'une altercation
entre deux hommes qui se seraient
réfugiés dans le wagon restaurant
quelques minutes avant que la bombe
n'explose
mais dans l'immédiat les enquêteurs en
sont réduits à quelques émotions
les gendarmes ne néglige aucun détail
chaque pouce de terrain est
systématiquement fouillés des papiers
personnels ont été récupérés déchiré
broyés par l'explosion la question que
l'on se pose également la charge
explosive vise est elle vraiment le
capitole et ses 300 passagers ou bien la
bombe est elle destinée à un autre
objectif
ce qu'on peut constater c'est
qu'effectivement il ya un souffle très
violent des projections vers le haut du
wagon et soufflé vers la partie arrière
du des wagons et va seulement un effet
de souffle puisque l'on voit en
particulier la cabine qui voulaient
quelque fois sans en souffler donc il
s'agit pas simplement d'une valise
contenant une certaine charge
d'explosifs qui a été placé à cet
endroit du wagon
carlos ou johnny ou salles nc deux
autres surnoms s'appellerait vladimir
ilitch sanchez
ici ils se trouvent sur l'aéroport
d'alger après la prise d'otage des
ministres de l'opep à vienne en décembre
carlos au début je l'avais pris pour un
mafioso italien raconté un de ses
anciens complices
puis il m'est apparu comme une sorte de
james bond il serait originaire d'une
grande famille vénézuélienne parlerait
six langues vivraient dans l'opulence il
ferait payer très cher ses services de
mercenaires
un homme ou des hommes auxquels on
attribue de nombreuses actions en france
il apparaît pour la première fois en
juin 1975 à l'occasion d'une fusillade
rue toullier à paris à son domicile
il abat deux inspecteurs de la dsp c'est
la première fois que l'on évoque
l'organisation de la lutte armée arabe
celle là même qui revendique le double
attentat de samedi soir le 15 août 1975
on évoque le nom de carlos dans
l'attentât du peuple saint germain qui
fait 2 morts et 33 blessés
des représailles contre l'état français
qui refusait de libérer les membres d'un
commando qui avait attaqué l'ambassade
de france à la haye
quelques mois plus tôt le 29 mars 1982
on voit sa main derrière l'explosion qui
tue cinq personnes et fait 27 blessés
dans le capitole
cet attentat ne sera jamais revendiqué
mais carlos avait auparavant adressé à
gaston defferre ministre de l'intérieur
un ultimatum authentifié exigent la
libération de mcb est née la coop et
bruno bréguet sur cette photo de membres
de son organisation le 27 mars le délai
de l'ultimatum est écoulé le 29 le
capitole et plastiquées
carlos revendique l'attentât contre la
maison de france à berlin qui fait un
mort et 23 blessés le 25 août 1983
s'agit-il de carlos terroristes
professionnels ou d'une organisation qui
utilisent ce nom la question se pose à
nouveau pour les deux attentats de
samedi
voici ilitch ramirez sanchez dit carlos
le terroriste numéro un
il a à son actif un palmarès sans égale
1974 prise d'otages de l'ambassade de la
n 15 septembre 74 attentats au drugstore
saint-germain à paris de morts 30
blessés décembre 75 prise d'otage des
ministres de l'opep à vienne après cet
attentat il se réfugie à alger où on le
voit sur cette photo
toujours en 75 à paris deux inspecteurs
de la dst et un de leurs informateurs
sont habitués rue toullier toujours
carlos et puis plus récemment le 29 mars
l'explosion dans le capitole 5 morts et
27 blessés
s'il n'a pas revendiqué cet attentat
carlos avait auparavant adressé à gaston
defferre ministre de l'intérieur un
ultimatum exigeant la libération de deux
terroristes arrêtés à paris le 27 mars
le délai de l'ultimatum est écoulé le 29
mars
c'est l'explosion du capitole autant de
faits et de présomptions qui explique
pourquoi les policiers prennent très au
sérieux
la revendication par l'organisation de
la lutte armée arabe des attentats de la
saint sylvestre organisation d'ailleurs
dont faisait partie carlos mais c'est
l'organisation qui a revendiqué ces
attentats pas carlos lui même alors
peut-on attribuer ces attentats au
terroriste numéro un
ou est ce une part ternie tu es un peu
forcé
22 avril son plan de jeu mardi à 9
heures du mans
une voiture bourrée d'explosifs un mort
63 blessés auteur présumé de l'attentât
carlos accompagne magdalena kopp
comparaissait quelques heures plus tard
devant un tribunal correctionnel de
paris le 7 juin dernier jean louis
bruguière dans le cadre de son
instruction sur cet attentat
lance un mandat d'arrêt contre le
terroriste un premier mandat d'arrêt
avait déjà été lancé sans succès le 9
janvier 1976 quelques mois après le
meurtre rue toullier à paris de deux
inspecteurs de la dst les deux hommes
étaient venus arrêter car l'ours
carmeuse les abeilles aux côtés de
charles pasqua cet après-midi le patron
actuel de la direction de la
surveillance du territoire n'avait pas
oublié une fidélité au souvenir de ceux
qui sont morts de celui qui a été baissé
une fidélité aux veuves aux orphelins et
et à gage de professionnalisme
quelque chose de très important pour la
dst et surtout on se donnait du 50
heures pour ce service
un anniversaire pour la dst en met une
année à venir apurer difficile pour la
justice le 1er juin 1982
l'osce avait été condamné par contumace
à la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
selon le droit français doit à présent
être rejugé par la cour d'assises de
paris uniquement composée de magistrats
une formation spéciale pour les affaires
de terrorisme
en attendant le procès la france
doit-elle craindre d'autres attentats
réponse de monsieur pasqua je ne le sais
pas
c'est possible mais je ne le crois pas
de toute façon il est normal qu'un pays
qui a été victime d'un certain nombre
d'attentats terroristes et dont un
certain nombre de citoyens ont été
assassinés passant forte
le responsable de ces attentats soient
traduits devant la justice dès demain
carlo sera présenté au juge bruguière
l'homme à la pipe qui rentrent de
vacances et qui devrait le mettre en
examen dans le cadre de l'attentât de la
rue marbeuf
en attendant sûrement de ré ouvrir
d'autres informations contre les
terroristes
pour tous les autres attentats qui l'a
vraisemblablement que mon empreinte
ben quoi qu'il en soit cette arrestation
représente la revanche passion de la dst
qui suivit carlos à la trace depuis près
de 20 ans après l'assassinât à paris de
deux policiers de ce service récit
l'autre sans père la traque de carlos
elle commence en france le 15 septembre
1974 une grenade explose boulevard
saint-germain drug stores de morts 34
blessés le premier attentat signé carlos
en france un an plus tard trois
inspecteurs de la dst se présente à la
porte d'un appartement rue toullier au
numéro 9 dans le quartier latin
carlos est là il abat froidement deux
inspecteurs d'une balle en pleine tête
et blesse grièvement le troisième tous
les services français se mobilisent
il faut loger carlos et le neutraliser
et donc confier sa au service action
le service action était dirigée par un
homme remarquable c'est remarquable qui
est elle verra de marolles maintenant à
la retraite et il a lui-même nommé
dans cette mission de chasse comme chef
de cette opération
c'est tout à fait spécial un officier
remarquable qui est l'homme dans le fond
qu'il vient de capturer carlos karine de
traque de privas attend c'est delphine
pando le général philippe rondot un
homme très secret aucune photo n'existe
de lui spécialiste du terrorisme
moyen-orientale celui qui retrouve
carlos ici au soudan au début de l'année
il le fils à plusieurs reprises et c'est
lui-même qui prend ces photos du
terrorisme après mystère lors de sa
conférence de presse hier charles pasqua
a livré très peu de détails sur
l'arrestation et sur le transfert de
carlos l'acheminement de carlos vers
paris alors été organisée la dst s'est
assuré de sa personne à son arrivée à
villacoublay
les autorités judiciaires ont été
immédiatement informées dès aujourd'hui
mes trousses et dit qu'un avocat de
carlos n'hésite pas à parler
d'enlèvement selon lui carlos a été
droguée ligotés pendant 12 heures est
accompagné dans l'avion par des agents
de la dst cagoulés qui l'a reconnu à la
voie au ministère de l'intérieur on
refuse toute polémique pas de
commentaire les conditions du transfert
de carlos ont classé secret défense
la traque de carlos elle commence en
france le 15 septembre 1974 une grenade
explose boulevard saint germain de
rockstore de morts 34 blessés le premier
attentat signé carlos en france un an
plus tard trois inspecteurs de la dst se
présente à la porte d'un appartement rue
toullier au numéro 9 dans le quartier
latin
carlos est là il abat froidement deux
inspecteurs d'une balle en pleine tête
et blesse grièvement le troisième tous
les services français se mobilisent
il faut loger carlos et le neutraliser
quand j'ai donc confier sa au service
action
le service action était dirigée par un
homme remarquable c'est remarquable qui
était verra de marolles qui maintenant à
la retraite et il a lui même nommé dans
cette mission de chasse comme chef de
cette opération tout à fait spécial un
officier remarquable qui est l'homme
dans le fond il vient de capturer carlos
karine bracq bva attend c'est général
philippe rondot le général philippe
rondot un homme très secret aucune photo
n'existe de lui spécialiste du
terrorisme moyen-orientale celui qui
retrouve carlos ici au soudan au début
de l'année il le fils à plusieurs
reprises et c'est lui-même qui prend ces
photos du terroriste après mystère lors
de sa conférence de presse hier charles
pasqua a livré prés peu de détails sur
l'arrestation et sur le transfert de
carlos l'acheminement de carlos vers
paris alors été organisée la dst s'est
assuré de sa personne à son arrivée à
villacoublay
les autorités judiciaires ont été
immédiatement informées dès aujourd'hui
mes trousses et dit qu'un avocat de
carlos n'hésite pas à parler
d'enlèvement selon lui carlos a été
droguée ligotés pendant 12 heures est
accompagné dans l'avion par des agents
de la dst cagoulés qui l'a reconnu à la
voie au ministère de l'intérieur on
refuse toute polémique pas de
commentaire les conditions du transfert
de carlos sont classés secret défense
paris et carlos de vieilles
connaissances à paris qu'il connaît bien
un pari où il vit c'est en 1974 qu'il y
laisse ses premières traces sanglantes
15 septembre une grenade au dr publicis
boulevard saint-germain deux morts 34
blessés vingt ans plus tard les mémoires
sont intactes
au début on a cru que c'était une bombe
ce que savait ou tremblay partout et en
vérité on a su après que c'était une
promenade quoi
on a commencé à organiser les soins quoi
les gens qui sortent et blessés et où on
a commencé à faire les gars au parc ou
carlos heurté par les lui quelques mois
plus tard janvier 75 il signe deux
attentats à orly contre les avions de la
compagnie d'el al mais carlos n'est pas
encore carlos il est encore ce jeune
homme fréquentant les quartiers
étudiants de paris i et appréciant les
jolies femmes
les bars la nuit et les discothèques sud
américaine mais à l'époque que nous
avons eu ici beaucoup de personnalité
c'est la personne que vous me demandez
si triste réalité
carlos n'aura un nom et un visage qu'à
partir du 27 juillet 75 quand il abat
deux policiers de la dst venus l'arrêter
rue toullier en 1979 dans une longue
interview au journal arabe el watan el
arabi il expliquera que l'opération ne
lui a pris que 6 secondes 1982 le sang
coule à nouveau
c'est l'attentât de la rue marbeuf à
morts et 63 blessés
c'est parfait c'est impressionnant a
raconté
même maintenant maintenant on n'aime pas
ailleurs forcé n'ont pas envie de dire
qu'on fait pour tous ceux qui n'ont pas
pu oublier le passage de carlos à paris
son retour aujourd'hui et un douloureux
souvenir est un soulagement
22 avril 80 de paris rue marbeuf à morts
et 63 blessés
l'attentât jamais revendiqué restait
pourtant le seul dossier qui permet
aujourd'hui au juge bruguière la mise en
examen de carlos seulement douze ans
après les faits le 7 juin dernier grâce
à des éléments nouveaux fournis par la
hongrie aujourd'hui plus généreuse avec
ses archives qu'à l'époque du rideau de
fer
mais le juge bruguière ne peut entendre
juridiquement le terroriste pour les
autres dossiers des dossiers dont les
avocats des victimes ont réclamé la
réouverture quelques semaines avant
l'arrestation de carlos
on a vu de bombay a transmis aux vertus
pour dénoncer d'une cape town de la gare
saint-charles je pense que c'est une
chimie treiber et d'après mes calculs
carlos devrait impliquer dans au moins
cinq affaires d'autres événéments
nouveau récemment
oui le jeu et d'instruction avait rendu
visite aux autorités est allemandes et
le rapport de la statique
or et des services secrets hongrois
d'autre part ont permis à mon avis des
avancées significatives dont la ferme et
à la gare saint-charles deux affaires
qui n'ont abouti qu'à des non lieu faute
de preuves
deux attentats l'un contre le capital en
mars 82 5 morts l'autre à marseille gare
saint-charles où 83 également cinq
personnes tuées pour la réouverture de
ces deux dossiers les charges nouvelles
nécessaire juge bruguière sont en sa
possession
grâce à la stasi la police politique de
l'ancienne allemagne de l'est qui a
donné la copie de notes échangés entre
les membres du groupe terroriste mettant
en cause carlos reste la sphère de la
rue tout y est ou deux agents de la dst
ont été tuées à paris en 75 la
condamnation par contumace du terroriste
doit être notifiée par le parquet pour
le juger aujourd'hui la chancellerie le
procureur général bruno côté la chambre
des affaires criminelles et des grâces
se sont réunis pour savoir quelle
solution juridique adopté une décision
devrait être prise jeudi
kate carlos a donc passé sa deuxième
nuit en prison le terroriste mise en
examen hier par le juge bruguière a été
placé sous mandat de dépôt carlos est
détenu sous le régime ordinaire à la
prison de la santé
mais pour ce prisonnier peu ordinaire
les syndicats de gardiens de prison
demande plus de moyens
l'autre sans père réjean paul guilloteau
un dps
un détenu particulièrement surveillé
carlos vient de passer sa deuxième nuit
à la maison d'arrêt de la santé à paris
troisième division dans un quartier
spécial le quartier d'isolement
carlos est au rez de chaussée au
deuxième étage se trouve le docteur
garetta et paul toungui
ici tout est fait pour que les détenus
ne se rencontrent jamais donc quatre
personnels de surveillance non gradés
plus abordé en permanence donc pour
carlos et donc pour la mesure
d'isolement
chaque fois qu'il fait un mouvement en
dehors de sa cellule il doit être
accompagné par par nos collègues que je
n'ai cité
donc à partir de là quatre surveillants
motion gradé pour simplement une
personne ça fait beaucoup quand on sait
qui a énormément de détenus donc à notre
à s'occuper
ceci dit ça fait partie de notre boulot
ou simplement et nous montrer des
effectifs et c'est ce qu'on réclame
depuis des années et au delà c'est le
problème des structures est ce que nous
souhaitons ne puis toujours des
établissements spécialisés pour garder
effectivement à ce genre d'individu
particulièrement dangereux pour la
société et notre job c'est de le garder
et de garder en toute sécurité
pour le reste carlos est soumis à un
régime de détention ordinaire
radiotélévision cigarettes boissons non
alcoolisées en revanche il est seule en
promenade et il peut déjeuner à la
cantine mais en horaires décalés deux
fois par semaine il recevra la visite
d'un médecin qui peut émettre un avis
sur le maintien ou non en isolement
selon le ministère de la justice la
santé offre toutes les garanties de
sécurité
l avantage d'être proche du palais de
justice carlos devrait donc y rester
jusqu'à son procès
pressé m oussedik mais s'ils vont
rassembler suffisamment d'éléments près
de carry est content des deux pouvaient
plier enlèvement l'enlèvement souci
numéro un de son avocat préoccupé pour
l'instant par cette excuse aussi et
parier
rentrant chez eux
le fond du dossier vous savez si c'est
pour discuter de la fête l'attentât de
la la rue marbeuf vous en connaissez des
tenants et les aboutissants messieurs
ramirez sanchez a dit être étranger à
cette attente a balayé d'un revers de
main l'attentât de la rue marc carlos
semble apparemment toujours au 6e rang
face aux risques qu'ils encourent et
pourtant
l'étau se resserre sur ilitch ramirez
sanchez mais là encore son éventuelle
implication dans les attentats du train
toulouse paris en 1982 et dans celui de
la gare saint charles à marseille en
1983 nous y aurait fait ni chaud ni
froid lui ai dit ça la fait sourire
il comprend pas sur ce point elle est
très tranquille je pense que on attribue
beaucoup de choses à carlo nous carlos
n'a pas l'air très inquiet par tous que
la justice française ne reproche son
souci ce matin éviter qu'on le réveille
tes vingt minutes durant les rondes de
nuit
il est fatigué il voudrait dormi
15 septembre 1974 drug stores saint
germain à paris en fin d'après midi une
bombe explose de morts 34 blessés ce
jour-là à nichols était venu acheter des
journaux et moi j'étais terrier le lien
genre de photos qui est là au milieu
juste et là et bon après il y avait de
la glace partout des morceaux de verre
les gens qui criaient et moi même donc
j'ai vu que mon corps était fortement
des chips et ensuite où les jambes et
les mains et les bras à nicole se passe
ensuite de longues années à l'hôpital
elle s'en sortira sans séquelles graves
20,79 carlos revendique l'attentât mais
en 1983 l'instruction judiciaire est
close par un non lieu
onze années passent et carlos est arrêté
cet été à nicole savas aussitôt à sos
attentats pour savoir si malgré la
prescription
le dossier peut être rouvert c'est à 30
ans était prescrite
alors
je trouvais quand même que
carlos devaient être jugés pour cet acte
hier carlos a été assigné à comparaître
devant le tribunal civil de paris il ne
pourra être condamné qu'à verser des
indemnités aux victimes
mais cette procédure est le seul moyen
de contourner la prescription pénale
nous savons bien si vous voulez que
carlos sont donc ne paiera jamais et
dommages et intérêts auxquels il sera
condamné envers les victimes
mais il convient que là aussi la justice
passe et il est encore temps et nous
avons profité de cette opportunité que
nous offrait la loi pour le faire
qu'elle soit indemnisée ou pas et quel
que soit le tribunal les victimes
veulent avant tout que carlos répondre
enfin devant les juges de l'attentât qui
a bouleversé leur vie
allemagne de l'est et suisse les deux
nations qui ont bénéficié de ces cette
première soirée de sur le vélodrome de
san cristóbal à ce championnat du monde
cycliste les médailles françaises se
font rares en fait une autre course
poursuite vient de commencer une chasse
dont carlos et le gibier
il était le seul à pouvoir s'en douter
heureux hasard de l'époque le directeur
de l'équipe de france était un ancien
des services spéciaux quelques mois
avant l'épreuve sportive à berlin un ex
collègue lui avait tenu une curieuse
conversation et à un moment donné il m'a
dit il y a le cas carlos est ce que le
gaz est rendue accepteraient de nous
aider naturellement ma réponse était oui
mais c'est tout
cinq agents français traquent le célèbre
terroriste sur ses terres parmi eux un
certain max philippe rondot de son vrai
nom il guette tout signe que pourrait
donner carlos à son père que l'on voit
ici comme au reste de la famille
la chasse a débuté depuis deux ans déjà
les services sont en alerte
à lui seul le dossier français
volumineux peu à peu les recherches vont
montrer qu'un même homme peut se cacher
derrière une série d'attentats les
bombes devant les journaux l'aurore
l'arche minutes et la maison de la radio
les grenades lancées au drugstore
saint-germain de morts 34 blessés rue
toullier deux hommes du
contre-espionnage assassiné de même que
leur indique michel mouillart balle et
surtout la prise d'otage de 70 personnes
à vienne
les onze plus importants ministres du
pétrole sont là vingt-quatre heures
après en quittant l'autriche carlos
salue chaleureusement ce qu'ils libèrent
il laisse derrière lui trois morts et
l'homme ses lieutenants hans joachim
klein grièvement blessé il a survécu
depuis vingt ans ils errent tels un
soldat perdu il s'est repenti
selon lui carlos fut sans pitié pour ses
victimes pendant l'opération deviennent
alors que l'homme était donc hors combat
carlos lee a vidé tout son chargeur dans
le corps c'était un massacre de la pure
frime
à son arrivée à alger carlos libère ces
derniers otages
cette fois il est filmé et photographié
sous toutes les coutures
c'est lui qui court sur le tarmac il
embauchera plusieurs dizaines de
millions de dollars
le mythe carlos est née après
l'opération de décembre 75
carlos est plus que jamais dans la ligne
de mire des services aideront d'eau en
particulier il accumule des
renseignements sur les trafics de faux
papiers
les empreintes digitales du terroriste
l'information circule carlos agace ceux
dont il se revendique
les palestiniens les extrémistes comme
georges habache et en particulier wadie
haddad celui qui l'avait recruté le
lâche carlos le fedayin devient un
mercenaire la traque se poursuit pour
carlos les sanctuaires sont épisodiques
un peu partout dans le monde
au proche orient à l'est budapest
bucarest son ultime défi faire libérer
sa future épouse est un compagnon
d'armes arrêté en 82 en france
nouvelle succession d'attentats contre
le capitole 5 morts soit 117 blessés rue
marbeuf un mort 63 blessés ultime étape
khartoum au soudan depuis plusieurs mois
rondeau suit le retraité carlos paz a
pas jusque dans ces réjouissances
nocturne
15 août 94 rondeau enlève carlos et le
livre à la justice
la traque aura duré ou des trois
décennies
elle se sera déroulé sous toit
présidence de la république jusqu'à son
terme aujourd'hui qui est de termes
judiciaires et avec toujours à sa tête
un seul et même homme
rondeau l'absolu contraire de carlos lui
il fuit tout renommée médiatique
c'est aujourd'hui un retraité paisible
c'était en 75 le patron de
l'antiterrorisme à la dst jambaque
antilles en kata l'époque sur les
raisons palestine en europe ab de carlos
il ne sait encore rien tout commence
avec la fille nature de cet homme michel
boucard balle à libanais l'attesté le
surveille le photographier même sans le
savoir ici en compagnie de cartes sous
puis l'interpellent et l'interrogent
bocar bâ ne parle très très peu à ce
moment là il a un tout juste donner son
identité
il n'a pas reconnu sa mission et
refusent de nous donner des
renseignements je peux je qualifierais
d'opérationnel puis sous la menace d'une
expulsion nous car bâle pas libre le
monde de l'inconnu de la photo carlos et
guide les policiers vers la route où
vivent pas dans l'appartement
les inspecteurs de la dst trouve des
étudiants sud américain et carlos qui
désignait par mon quart balthus son
complice libanais tu es abat froidement
les deux fonctionnaires de police
les hommes de jean baklouti n'était pas
armé ce soir là l'opération a été un peu
plus mal monté au tec c'est vrai qu'on
aurait dû prendre d'autres précautions
mais vous savez pour un flic c'est après
coup que souvent commencer par soi qu'il
ya une bavure échos n'aurait pas dû
faire comme cela mais voilà carlos cette
échappée seule chance pour la police
italie si des empreintes sa traque
commence
''mon deux ans après carlos ses avocats
dénoncent un complot politique
il s'appuie sur les confidences
ancien agent des services secrets
israéliens qui affirme que le mossad
était présent dooly la rue toullier est
un crime de haute trahison des temps de
hauts fonctionnaires français ont
organisé avec des agents du mossad
représente donc une puissance étrangère
la provocation de la rue toullier bon
pour entraîner la rupture des accords
entre les organisations palestiniennes
et l'état français
de sa cellule il y a quelques semaines
carlos a même écrit au président de la
cour d'assises qui va le juger
il dénonce dans cette lettre un complot
sioniste jambes à l'outil luis nani
admiration ni haine pour ce terreau
empli de green a traqué pendant 15 ans
il suivra simplement le procès avec
attention
dernière journée du procès de carlos à
paris les plaidoiries des avocats de la
défense ont commencé ce matin le verdict
est attendu en fin de journée hier
l'avocat général de la cour d'assises à
recul a requis la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité contre ilitch ramirez sanchez
agnès vahramian bruno livertout aux
dernières paroles de l'avocat général
carlo sable ou applaudi et félicité
celui qui venait de demander la prison à
vie contre l'accusé
pour ses avocats ce n'est pas une
surprise rien d'inattendu et je crois
que si l'avocat général avait pu il
aurait requis la peine de mort votre
décision ne sera pas une décision de
guerre ou de vengeance mais simplement
l'application de la loi de la république
ces mots de l'avocat général ont semblé
soulager les familles touchées par le
comportement de carlos que je regrette
aujourd'hui c'est que carlos
effectivement comme le dit l'avocat
général
nous ne nous est pas dit voilà j'ai tué
votre père j'avais de bonnes raisons
pour le faire je le regrette je ne le
regrette pas mais je les fais ça n'est
pas un instrument qui ressent que tout
être humain veut un respect du prochain
c'est une info j'ai résumé carlos ne
voulait pas de ce procès prétendait se
défendre seul depuis ce matin sa
stratégie véritable ses avocats commis
d'office plaident pour lui la défense a
tenté de jeter le trouble sur la
présence rue toullier ce soir-là de
carlos
elle a aussi fait part de ses doutes sur
l'opération de la dst on vous cache
quelque chose
ont plaidé les avocats carlos eu écoute
mais un peu distrait et sans conviction
il attend la plaidoirie politique celle
qui fera de lui un combattant
révolutionnaire un héros mais carlos
sait déjà qu'il a perdu la partie
c'est la nuit dernière après quinze
jours de procès que le terroriste carlos
a finalement été condamné à la prison à
perpétuité pour le triple meurtre de la
rue toullier en 1975 à paris après ses
défenseurs carlos en personne s'est
lancé dans une invraisemblable
plaidoirie de plus de quatre heures mais
qui finalement n'a pas influencer les
jurés
agnès vahramian bruno livertout il est
armé il esquisse un sourire
ce verdict les fils des victimes
l'attendait depuis 22 ans
apaisé ils ne sont pour autant pas
satisfait j'aurais quand même aimé
entendre j'ai tué votre père et pour
telle raison ça j'ai pas entendu
j'espère que carlo cela dit il y aura
une suite à ce procès j'espère qu'un
jour je l'entends il tourne autour du
pot il veut pas aborder les faits et il
assume pas ce qu'il a fait puisqu'il a
un peu il a honte de ce qu'il a fait par
rapport à ces idéologies pendant ce
procès carlos n'a pas nier n'a pas avoué
non plus ses crimes il n'a simplement
pas voulu coopérer avec cette justice
qui l'a condamné dit-il par avance
c'est un combattant communiste que l'on
a voulu condamner et c'est à ce titre là
qu'il peut être qu'il peut considérer
que cette condamnation confirme le
caractère exclusivement politique de
cette procédure
pour autant les avocats de carlos commis
d'office ont soulevé des incohérences
des manques comme l'absence des témoins
à la barre c'est un peu dommage que le
procès carlos ont été expédiés en huit
jours au pas de charge par la cour
d'assises de paris parce que je crois
qu'on a montré qu'ils posaient beaucoup
de questions
c'était la première condamnation de
carlos qui est mis en examen dans quatre
dossiers de terrorisme encore à
l'instruction
après le verdict le rideau est tombé la
représentation de carlos et que terminer
la salle s'est vidée le jury est parti
une autre audience a commencé si vous ni
celle là sans enjeu et nous avons
assisté à un moment de vérité
un avocat de la partie civile s'est
accroché et de carlos tout près pour lui
demander mais pourquoi ne pas avoir
avoué les crimes de la rue toullier
carlos a alors répondu parce que ce
n'était pas une manière de faire le
procès puis il a insisté la rue toullier
n'était pas un attentat
c'était une arrestation avons-nous
compris à laquelle il s'agissait
résister puis carlos a quitté le box en
souriant sur ce qui ressemblait à un
demi aveu
là
store saint germain à paris c'était le
15 septembre 74 une grenade explose à
l'intérieur du magasin on relève deux
morts et 34 blessés
principal accusé carlos de son vrai nom
ilitch ramirez sanchez
à cette époque il n'est pas encore
connue un an plus tard il prend en otage
les ministres du pétrole de l'opep
réunis à vienne
carlos devient alors la figure de proue
du terrorisme international
pendant vingt ans carlos multiplient les
attentats en europe
jusqu en août 94 quand il est arrêté au
soudan et ramener en france
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité en décembre 97 pour le triple
meurtre de la rue toullier carlos devait
encore répondre de cinq autres
accusations dont l'attentât du drugstore
saint-germain
aujourd'hui la cour d'appel de paris a
accordé un non-lieu à carlos les juges
estiment que le dossier ne contient
aucune charge suffisante
un revers pour le juge antiterroriste
bruguière qui a instruit tout la faire
ce soir
l'un des avocats de carlos à lui une
première victoire de son client soit la
justice française de son côté
l'association sos attentats annonce son
intention de se pourvoir en cassation
une démarche adoptée également par le
parquet général de paris
une grenade vient d'exploser à côté de
cette brasserie la cible inde rockstore
très fréquentée du boulevard saint
germain
bilan deux morts et 34 blessés un
attentat revendiqué par carlos dans un
entretien publié en 1979
et depuis c'est le seul élément retenu à
sa charge dans ce dossier instruit par
le juge antiterroriste jean louis
bruguière 24 ans après les faits la cour
d'appel de paris vient de clore cette
affaire par manque de preuves
donnant droit à la requête déposée par
ses défenseurs
le principe c'est la présomption
d'innocence je ne vois pas pourquoi
carlos comme roland dumas ou qui que ce
soit n'auraient pas droit à la
présomption d'innocence
je dis donc les juges en ont eu assez
des juges sur l'accusation n'ont eu
assez de servir d'alibi à des intérêts
politiques qui ne sont pas ceux de la
justice à savoir la recherche de la
vérité et ils ont donc tranché
pour l'association sos attentats selon
lui est aussi inattendue que choquant
elle entend d'ailleurs se pouvoir en
cassation dès lundi pour vice de
procédure
forcément que c'est plus ma nage
en mémoire des victimes de 1974 et
drague forts et les sodas ces mêmes
issus tous puissent échapper à la
justice pour un crime qu'il a revendiqué
ce non lieu ne bouleversera pas le sort
de carlos en 97 il est condamné à
perpétuité pour l'assassinât de deux
policiers un crime commis rue toullier à
paris le 27 juin 75
bref carlos ne quittera pas la prison de
la santé où il séjourne depuis 94
sans compter les autres procédures
toujours en cours contre l'ancien chef
terroriste